we're now going to take a look at some
of magnus carson's five best moments from
chess.com's previous online competitions in
preparation for the big one you're going to
be watching aren't you make sure you're
watching only a couple of weeks the 2020
chess.com speed chess championships remember
to like and subscribe to this channel and we'll
move over to example number one for beginner oh
look at that hikaru nakamura right as i said it
he trapped his own queen robert you missed it he
trapped his own queen i mean that's just you know
that's going to be absolutely heartbreaking
for hikaru absolutely in this first example
hikaru has the white pieces and he gets himself
in a little bit of a discombobulated muddle puddle
disaster zone now magnus traps his queen in very
nice style maybe not the most amazing tactics but
i'm sure again magnus would have enjoyed hikaru
now should have brought his queen back somewhere
well d3 the only square instead he goes to where
four how does that queen now find itself stranded
in really the middle of the board g5 this move
traps the queen and hikaru resigned immediately
it's very peculiar to get a queen trapped like
that but if the queen tries to run away to f3
bishop g4 meets make sure it has no other escape
route so a nice little simple victory for carlson
we're starting easy they're going to get a
little more difficult and let's move on to
the next one now yeah i'll be doing it and
i guess his idea is after king f2 bishop c4
he's actually threatening mate with queen
takes e3 king of uh yeah queen takes e3 and uh
no this is this is just over this is just like a
wipeout in round in round one one thing that makes
these top players stand out is their tactical
ability and their vision their ability to see
tactics instantaneously bang like a lightning
bolt us mere mortals just cannot keep up with them
in this game wesley so has just played f4 but
this allows a winning combination can you see
the combination which comprises of many small
parts first of all magnus plays bishop d4 you
should always look for the most challenging move
a move that's gonna put your opponent on the back
foot this is attacking the e pawn that pawn cannot
capture the bishop because the rook is on pretty
maybe wesley thought he was okay after rook to e1
but now comes the second stage bishop takes e free
check rook takes e3 and now one more capture on e3
and here comes the next stage of the tactic queen
d4 and really when playing this whole idea with
bishop d4 you needed to be able to see up to this
moment and even one will move deeper this rook
is in what we can call an eternal pin it can't
move because the king will be in check and if
black is simply allowed to play rook takes e3
it's curtains time so king f2 is the only option
but now bishop takes c4 the final move the queen
is attacked on b3 and wherever the queen moves to
queen takes e3 will win the game and again it's
just this vision that we all need to improve our
own chess but these guys they are just so quick so
fast hence making the champions that they are
and you're right back in that critical moment
we saw that magnus you know his sixth sense or
whatever he played this move d7 everybody right
when grisham didn't have much time you can see on
the analysis board and that's what got sasha f6
and the f7 check is coming right yeah rookie back
king d8 f7 game one and uh and already magnus does
what he does best he just swindled his way to
a victory based mainly on the fact that grisha
didn't have enough time to solve the issues to
solve the landmine of tricks that magnus laid out
spotting tactics at any moment in the game whether
it be the opening middle game and ending is key
it's all good and fair getting a good position
in the ending but if you missed the win you might
miss your opportunity here we see magnus with the
white pieces playing against grizzchuk the chess
gangster the og of the chessboard how did now
magnus use a little series of moves to force the
win of a piece or queening of the pawn the first
move is pretty obvious but can you see the next
steps well he first plays f6 threatening
just to slam that pawn all the way into f8
there's only one way to stop it and you've got to
consider your opponent's best defensive move so
hopefully you saw bishop to g6 and now the key
move f7 check this is the move you needed to
see there's only one way to stop that queening
and here white can play rook 2e7 check the final
piece of the puzzle the king cannot hold on to the
bishop well if it does it will be going into the
line of white's bishop and rook to e2 discovered
check will win that rook on c2 magnus being a rook
up and if king to d8 has played in the game just
rook takes off seven magnus has won a piece he's
pretty good in the ending anyway you don't really
want to give him peace odds as well as that not
a wise idea and he went on to clear up in quite
quick time here in this next example we're gonna
see magnus carson's attacking ability in full
motion his opponent is tigran petrosian petrosian
of the new age not the old age and in this
position magnus has the two bishops but what move
forces its way through and the breakthrough into
black's actual structure the move is rook takes g6
a lovely move here this opens up the black king
if the king takes the rook bishop f5 is checkmate
and if the queen takes the rook bishop f5 simply
wins the queen and after rook takes g6 tigran
resigned because there's no good way to stop
the rook coming in to g7 a nice sweet and simple
tactic there in this next one tigran petrossian
is again on the receiving end of some punishments
not for the first time in his life but it's this
attack which comes from nowhere which makes this
very special we have what looks like kind of a
long ending but what move did magnus now play
spotting an opportunity which many other
players would not have seen knight takes
g5 does this lose a piece no it draws
the black king into a really bad position
for example now black played knight to get to
f8 but clearly here black's just lost the pawn
you don't want to do that against magnus the
point though is if king takes g5 rook takes e6
places the black king into a checkmate position
f4 the very pretty and deadly fret and the only
way to stop this would be knight f6 but after
f4 and something like g5 to continue the piece
has won back with an easily winning game magnus
there demonstrating some beautiful tactical vision
in i suppose what you could say some nice crisp
and simple tactics will he become 2020s chess.com
speedchest champion make sure you keep your eyes
open make sure you don't miss any of the games
there it's gonna be brilliant to see i'm not sure
who can beat magnus but if there is one person
you'd have to bet on hikaru well let's well we're
gonna have to wait and see what you guys reckon
do like and subscribe to this video and
hopefully i'll be back again soon with more